you to resist early I hope you guys had
a often Doctor Who week I know I did
I hope you're all recovering from the
phantasms we didn't see the BBC just
posted a teaser for the Christmas
special
and since we now know some things about
what the story is going to be
as well some things about series 8 gonna
be fun to do an early review
going to be doing might top five things
to look for in the Christmas special
as well as some things in series a I'm
also going to be doing a video from the
Easter eggs on the fiftieth anniversary
special this week so be sure to
subscribe to get that too
so here we go to top five things to look
forward to in the Christmas special
number five
pre serious event rental or so if you
thought the doctor is going to be
landing
on transwell or before the war that
killed him
as you can see we have a
behind-the-scenes image that shows green
that means that things are not dead yet
obviously when we visited transl
ordering 37 turn the name at the doctor
everything with dead it was basically
like a graveyard jiang graveyard for the
whole planet
this means that will be visiting trends
lower before that happened
for those that are confused trends laura
is just the final graveyard to the
doctor it's not going to be the
graveyard the eleventh Doctor
so however many more years the BBC
continues to make Doctor Who that final
doctor
that will be his graveyard unless they
change things but they do with the time
ordered the fiftieth anniversary episode
number four Monster Mash so they're
going to be four different types the
Doctor Who villains very iconic villains
in the episode at the same time this
never happened before
they'll be the silent as you can see
sounds of all da Lex
Cybermen and weeping angels it's unclear
as to whether or not they all appear in
the same scenes
but it's kinda imply that they will
based on the prophecy in the question's
going to be asked number three
the story so Steven Moffat has said that
the story will basically wrap-up
all Matt Smith 10-year all those running
plot thread so
everything's calling back all the way to
the eleventh hour episode
the biggest part of the story will
obviously be the silence thousands fall
the props the basically says that when
the question is asked no creature can
speak falsely or fail to answer
and the reason the sounds were trying to
kill a doctor during 36
is because they thought that he was the
only one who knew the answer to the
question
obviously the Doctor Who question mark
question the interesting thing about
this is that it does imply that the
doctor will have to say his name I like
his true name
obviously in 37 during the name in the
doctor he said that name
actually is an important thing he chose
for himself is the doctor
if you saw the docudrama an adventure in
space and time William Hartnell is
actually one of the first people to ask
with that we see on camera asking doctor
who
question mark could be paying off a
moment from real life as well as this
big story that's been running on a
doctor who number two the regeneration
and the first
Bowl appearance Peter Capaldi Steven
Moffat has said that Matt Smith's doctor
number eleven will find regeneration and
death
profoundly terrifying and he will not
want to go just like David Tennant
his regeneration in 212 be just as
promised I thing as tens our generation
into 11
because Matt Smith will regenerate
wearing the same clothes pick up all the
will not have his new outfit until the
first episode of series a
we're not gonna see that for basically
like nine months we do know something
about Thursday and my number one thing
to look for tuna Christmas special
series a so Christmas specials that have
involved every generation
always tease a little bit at the town
over the next year is going to be but
because in the fiftieth anniversary
we also know some big running plot
threads that just started
mainly the search for Gallifrey like
Matt Smith said during his boys over at
the into the fiftieth anniversary
episode
I've never known where I'm going but now
I do I'm going home the long way around
so I miss the series 8 is going to
involve the search for Gallifrey
and it's widely rumored that Peter Cup
all these run will be much shorter than
Matt Smith run was
so it could be either one season or two
seasons so it's likely
the search for Gallifrey will basically
and at the end of the parties run an
answer is nine will incorporate the Time
Lords into its stories as well as the
stories and seasoned going forward
just like classic you did but let me
know what you got the Christmas special
teams are
obviously it was only 11 seconds on so
we're going to get a full trailer at
some point they'll have some more
details about the story is going to be
as was counties is going to be in it the
girl in the voiceover was not Kara so we
don't know if cars going to be
in the Christmas special so remember
this Thursday or Friday I'll be posting
that he straight video for the fiftieth
anniversary
and then after that I've also got a
video for my top five for generations
be sure to subscribe to get it thank you
all so much for your support during
doctor who week
I hope you enjoy the live stream and the
fiftieth anniversary special as much as
I did
it was so amazing right now click here
to get my review
the fiftieth anniversary officer and
click here to get my review
have an adventure in space and time
they're both amazing everybody go we
watch them right now
I'll see you later tonight i5 them